[Music]
welcome to the quick start tutorial for
the data loss prevention api
in this video we're going to walk
through how to get started with the dlp
api
which allows you to discover classify
and protect your most sensitive data
to start make sure you have a google
cloud project set up in the google cloud
platform console with billing enabled
you can either create a new project or
use an existing project
next enable the dlp api in the
navigation menu
click on apis and services click the
enable apis and services button at the
top
search for data loss prevention and
select it from the results
on the dop api page click enable to
enable it for the project
now set up a service account for
authentication purposes
in the navigation menu click on iam and
admin
service accounts click create service
account
at the top give your service account a
name
and click create
give your service account the role of
cloud dlp
dlp user click continue
and then done on the right side of your
screen click the three dots icon for the
service account you just created
and click create key then click create
this will download a service account key
json file to your computer
from command line set the environment
variable google underscore
application underscore credentials to
point to the json file you just
downloaded
now you will download some sample code
to your computer from command line using
git
once the repository has been cloned
navigate to node.js
dlp samples from here install
app dependencies by running npm install
this will download various packages
including the dlp client library for
node.js
next set the environment variable gcloud
underscore project to your google cloud
project id
now run the code in inspect string.js
this code inspects an input string with
the dlp api for sensitive data
and logs it to our console
for this example the script finds two
pieces of potentially sensitive data a
name and an email address and that's it
make sure to check out the rest of our
dlp api documentation to learn more
about how to discover
classify and protect your most sensitive
data
[Music]
you